hey guys today i'm going to be
explaining part two of my hero
academia's war arc
which involves some major casualties not
to mention a
crazy twist for shigaraki and a few more
clues as to the real identity of darby
although
come on guys we all know what it is but
uh yeah we get a few more clues
in this part if you haven't seen the
first video i did in this series then
i definitely recommend watching that
before this one as in that past video i
explained why the war is happening
and everything up until the death of
if we can get this video to 3 000 likes
then i'll drop part three in exactly two
weeks
so do be sure to hit that button if you
want more arc recaps like this
but without further ado let's get into
it and don't forget to sub
following on from the immediate
aftermath of twice's death
daby blasts hawks with some intense
flames once the number two hero avoids
the majority of the attack
his already depleted feathers have
caught fire meaning he has no more
weapons to defend himself
dabby approaches hawks in a rage and
steps on him for the second time
in this arc hawke's notes that dabby's
smiling expression
isn't exactly the face of someone who
just watched their friend get terminated
however
in dabi's defense he claims it's because
he has no more tear ducts because they
all got burnt up
which actually kind of made me feel a
bit bad for him despite him being a
serial murderer
the villain then ignites his flames
ensuring that hawks's back
is well and truly burnt to a crisp as
the fire rages on
bird boy reveals that he investigated
the background of the different villains
and the only ones he couldn't find
information on were shigaraki and darby
i've said this in a previous video but
for sugaraki it makes sense because he's
basically been off the grid since he was
about five or six years old
but in dabi's case what is the reason to
answer that
the scene then flashes back to a young
hawks when he was about to enter
a special government hero program the
guys in suits tell him
that in order to join the program he has
to give up his legal name
and endure some intense training which
plays into my theory that debbie was
also enrolled on this program
why else would hawks be thinking about
this memory at this moment
and why is debbie's real name so hard to
find maybe it's because
like hawks he had to give it up to
participate in this program
before the flashback ends we see how a
young hawks wanted to be just like
endeavour
when he was a kid coming back to the
present hawks asks dabby who he is
to which dabby does actually reply and
finally reveals his identity
the only problem is that in the manga
the speech bubble is blacked out
meaning that whilst hawks is able to
hear it and is visibly shocked
we as an audience are left completely in
the dark
i imagine dabi said something along the
lines of what you see on screen
but as of recording this video there is
no confirmation
as he goes to deal the finishing blow
you can see in hawks's eyes like he's
almost
accepted death at this point but at the
crucial moment
tokuyami appears out of the blue to save
his mentor
he arrived just in time because as i
explained in part one
when dabby blasted the number two hero
out of the window
hawks had to circle back around the
building and it was at this point when
he was doing that
that tokyomi caught a brief glimpse of
him and then went to investigate
now switching over to jakku hospital
mirko is still in a deadly tangle with
at least three higher nomus
and she notes how they're becoming
harder and harder to defeat as time
passes on
because they're beginning to stabilize
similar to hawks
she is also kind of accepted her death
and tells herself that if she's going to
die right now
then at least get the job done bouncing
around the nomus she presses on forward
to the area of the lab where shigaraki
is
but along the way she's just getting
absolutely torn to shreds they're
pulling her hair they're piercing her
skin in various ways
and of course by this point she had
already lost her arm so
it's just not a good day in the mirko
household that being said
none of that is enough to stop her from
approaching the tank
and her survival instincts are basically
telling her that under no circumstances
can shigaraki be released into the world
so she attempts to destroy the tank with
a kick but unfortunately
this is not successful due to this
really annoying
tentacle head no mu kind of just yanking
her back at the crucial moment
this sends her flying straight into
endeavour who had very recently entered
the lab with izawa and present mike
and a few other heroes as well whilst
mirko was pressing on forward
they were busy fighting the other hyenas
and this female nomu right here
displayed some great intelligence
in actively avoiding izaba's line of
sight so essentially it worked out that
aizawa could erase quirks
and so intentionally hid from him in
order to you know
operate at her full powers most likely
the smartest nomu we've ever seen
with the exception of kiragiri of course
by this point mirko is in really really
really bad shape and endeavour attempts
to cauterize her wounds to stop the
bleeding a bit
whilst an almighty battle is raging on
in the lab mirko lets the heroes know
over the radio that shigaraki is in the
capsule in the back of the lab
and they have to destroy it in order to
stop him from waking up
because izawa is pretty occupied by you
know erasing the quirks of the different
nomus
he tells president mike and another hero
called xls
to get in there and just do the job
finish off shigaraki
those two are able to then rush forward
towards shigaraki
partially thanks to the help of my boy
crust
as you can see in this panel he uses one
of his crusty shields to take out the
hyenomu
that was blocking their path present
mike then performed his biggest
accomplishment of the series so far
and shouts so loud that he just wrecks
the lab
shatters the glass capsule and sends dr
garaki flying away in the process
sugaraki's lifeless body collapses to
the ground as mike then runs up to the
doctor
and just wallops him across the face
this is obviously revenge for shirakumo
and also for making izaba cry
but also it's to check if the doctor is
real because
if you remember at the beginning of the
war they encountered the doctor but it
turned out to be a fake
xlus goes to restrain shigaraki but soon
realizes that he's not breathing at
all according to the doctor shiggy was
put into a death-like state
and the capsule was responsible for
preserving his life and reviving him
when necessary
with this thing now destroyed
shigaraki's heart is just not beating at
all
and pretty soon he will actually be dead
the remaining pro heroes begin to storm
into the lab
including the likes of gran torino rock
lock 13
and ryukyu working together they just
start
beating down on all the nomios that are
left and even the female one which was
the smartest one by far
she is finished off with a flash fire
fist to the face
as mike starts to drag dr garaki out the
lab
the scientist starts revealing a few
interesting bits of information about
his past
which directly tie into all for one
himself to summarize it
when the doctor was younger he presented
the quirk singularity theory
which basically is a theory that says as
long as quirks exist
they will keep on mixing until it
reaches a point where no human body can
sustain quirks
in the doctor's words no one took him
seriously and he was basically
excluded from society eventually
becoming homeless
during this dark time of his life afo
was the only person who reached out
and actually listened to what he had to
say therefore as a token of his
gratitude
the doctor decided to give his own quirk
to afo
which is called life force this power
doubled afo's lifespan
but meant that he was no longer as
athletic as he used to be
however as i explained in my video when
i was talking about the
best multiple quirk users afo used
several strength enhancing inquires to
get over this limitation
as a result the version of life force
that the doctor currently has
is simply a duplicate of the original
version
as the doctor continues his big speech
exeless notices
an unknown machine in the lab which he
cleverly decides to destroy
just to be on the safe side of things
this is going to be pretty important
later so it's a good thing that he did
this
garaki then says something pretty
shocking and that is that back in the
day
the quirk he really wanted to steal was
apparently izawa's erasure quirk
and not shurikumo's cloud ability
shirakumo obviously being kurogiri
so i mean this statement obviously has a
ton of implications
at the very least it means that dr
garaki was aware
of a young teenage izawa during his time
at ua
and was keeping tabs on him to at least
some extent
the scene then goes to this
inception-style dream world
where we see tomorrow sugaraki walking
in the ruins of
what i think is his childhood home
surrounded by rubble
and a bunch of decaying hands when we
look down at the city below
you can even see hands the size of
buildings emerging from the ground
as he wonders where he is the memory of
his sister
appears and she apologizes to him for
ratting him out when they were kids
we first saw this moment during the
maybelline academia arc
which occurred just before shigaraki
killed her
a giant apparition of his mother then
appears behind him
and she asks him if he still wants to be
a hero which again is a call back to a
scene that we saw in my villain academia
shigaraki then turns around to face her
and as he replies his body reverts back
to when he was a kid
before all for one got his hands on him
and put hands on him
his father then appears as well and we
see that tenko's expression changes from
one of being calm
to a face with just pure evil intentions
also
notice how his hair begins to change
color here and then
completely becomes white once his dad is
decayed
afo then appears to fill the void where
tenko's father had been
and calls out to the boy as tomorrow as
you can see
he's now back into his adult body and
afo ordered shigeraki towards him
you could also argue that this statement
here is almost like a metaphor
telling shiguraki to come to tartus
prison and rescue him
perhaps i mean that is one
interpretation of it as well
shiguraki's family appear behind him all
of them trying to pull him back and just
stop him from reaching afo
they're actually grabbing areas where
shigeraki would normally have had hands
on his body
his father and his grandmother nana
shimura both appear in one
last ditch attempt to stop what's about
to happen we always knew that shigaraki
wore the hand of his father on his face
but what's interesting is that we didn't
know the hand on the back of his head
was nana shimura's all along that means
that afo was planning this for literally
decades
because i mean nana shimura was killed
when even all might was a teenager so
afo's just had that hand in his freezer
for god knows how many years shiggy
decays all his family
and walks directly into the evil embrace
of his master it was at this moment that
we get the reveal from dr garaki
that afo anticipated that he would lose
to all might
and trusted everything to his successor
so in the same way that the doctor gave
his original quirk to afo
it's now that we get the reveal that afo
is giving his original quirk to
shigaraki
and with that a random piece of
electrical wiring touches the puddle of
fluids surrounding shiguraki's body
and in the blink of an eye he is jolted
back into action
now the hospital in which all of this is
happening is located in the mountains
and in the city directly below a bunch
of heroes and students are helping to
evacuate citizens as soon as shiguraki
is jolted back to life
deku's heart stops and we can clearly
see he feels a disturbance in the force
the voice of the first user of one floor
starts to reach out to him
but before we can get to that the manga
switches back over to hawks tokiyami and
darby
with tears in his eyes dark shadow says
that things are not looking good for
hawks right now
and his back is just completely gone
dabby points out
twice his corpse to tokyami and reveals
that it was hawks that killed him
he starts yapping on about how heroes
are more dirty than villains
before attempting to kill them both
which is a little bit hypocritical there
from darby
his fire singes tokiyami's legs and the
bright flames prevent dark shadow from
really going full power
meaning that both of the heroes are at a
major disadvantage
as darby continues to deliver this
amazing speech
hawks whispers that they need to leave
immediately because
dabi is only talking to stall for time
because his body needs to recover
in between attacks with hawks in his
arms tokiyami jumps off the ledge
and uses dark shadow as like a a weird
harness rope to swing down the number
two hero is not
completely unconscious due to the hard
landing and just as they think they're
safe
dabi pulls off an endeavor style move
and uses his feet as like
rocket boosters i guess you could call
it this gives him a totally
clean shot to kill both of these heroes
once and for all
just as dabi is about to secure the win
an enormous wall of ice just comes
crashing through the mansion
and disrupts the fight this was the work
of getting
who is a commander of the paranormal
liberation army and he basically used
this attack to send mount lady flying
backwards
giving us this beautiful work of art in
the process
getting rallies the troops and gives
them better instructions on taking on
the heroes
but you know by making this big attack
he's accidentally allowed tokiami enough
time
to escape the mansion with an
unconscious hawks
meanwhile inside the basement of the
mansion for the first time this arc
gigantomarcia actually stands up
as he now smells the scent of shigeraki
because he's come out of the capsule
this guy's nose right here it's just
it's just something else
going back to jakku whilst the
evacuation is underway
deku hears the voice of all for one's
younger brother who was the first user
of one for all
the brother warns that shigaraki has
become some kind of
all-powerful transcendent being and must
be stopped as soon as possible
deku clutches his stomach and starts
sweating which alerts todoroki and
bakugou
and also ochako everyone's just a little
bit concerned about deku right now
inside the hospital shigaraki sits up
next to
xlis which is sadly the last time we're
ever gonna see this hero
a wave of just super decay starts
emanating from out the lab
destroying everything in its path
including all of the quirks that dr
gracky had stored up over the years
this destruction heads straight for
present mike and the doctor
but luckily they're saved by gran torino
who just swoops in
and picks them up however many other
heroes were not so lucky
we just see a massive scramble to escape
the lab as it's being torn to shreds
if you look closely the rescue hero 13
is trying to stop the destruction rather
than running away
which might not be a good sign for her
fate flying heroes like endeavour and
ryukyu
they try to save as many people as they
can but
as izawa attempts to catch a ride he's
held back by one of the remaining nomus
that was still alive as the decay begins
to creep up this nomi's body and
eventually towards
a race ahead it's mere seconds away from
killing him
at the last second cross throws one of
his shields with enough force
to just chop off this nomu's arm in one
go freeing izawa and enabling him to fly
away
with ryukyu however despite his heroics
krust himself isn't able to move away in
time
and the decay quickly reaches him and
disintegrates his body
he uses his last seconds to give a
valiant thumbs up to izawa
with tears in his eyes which is typical
crust by this point the lab has now
totally just caved in and the decay is
ripping apart the hospital itself
and the surrounding area wash uses his
quirk
to keep some patients alive by putting
them in these floating bubbles
anyone who has a quirk that allows for
flight or levitation in some way
has definitely got the edge in this
situation the carnage continues to
spread out into the city
causing civilians heroes buildings and
even roads
all of it is just disintegrating we see
that the wild pussycats are caught up in
this mess
as pixie bob attempts to prevent the
decay from spreading
by using her earth flow quirk but you
know as you can see this is
unsuccessful and it's heavily implied
that they die in the process
although this remains to be confirmed
meanwhile at ground zero
sugar is causing all of this destruction
with just one of his hands
and he uses the other hand to steal xs
cape from him which is just like
mad disrespectful with the decay now
approaching deku in the gang
our protagonist powers up to 45 percent
of one for all
and delivers a powerful smash that
temporarily stops the decay from
progressing
this doesn't last very long though and
within a few seconds the street
continues to disintegrate
todoroki tries to step in and he
performs his heaven piercing ice wall
super move
but even that begins to crumble away
everyone kind of realizes at this point
that nothing is going to stop this
so especially just pack it up and start
running away they pick up as many
civilians as they can
and deku uses black whip in one of the
most impressive ways
that we've seen so far now you might
remember how earlier i mentioned how
exodus had seen a machine in the corner
and tried to destroy it well in this
moment shiggy walks towards it and it's
revealed
that this device is responsible for
manufacturing quirk destroying bullets
thanks to xs though like in death he did
do one good thing
and he basically shot the machine with
his laser eye and so most of the bullets
that were there
are now just ruined randomly though he
starts to hear a voice briefly like
intruding in his mind which confuses him
for a second
i'll talk about this more in part 3 when
it becomes relevant but yeah that's all
you need to know for now
sugar rocky notices a smartphone on the
ground that was used by dr garaki to
wake up the nomu
as well as do a bunch of other things he
picks it up and uses it for himself
to contact giganto makiya and in this
message he tells makiya
to come to jakku and bring the rest of
the league of villains
in his words this is the moment where
they destroy
everything macchia's eyes light up as he
begins to scream
and over in the mansion we see his
gigantic hand crashing
out of the basement where many of the
villains were actually trapped
this is an awesome panel and if you
notice toga's expression here
she's actually just finished a killing
spree of heroes
after disguising herself as that blue
guy who was murdered by twice
mr compress implies that her killing
spree was the result of twice's death
and that he's never seen her lose her
call like this before
finally this part ends back in jakku
just after shiguraki made the call to
giganto makia
endeavour comes flying in with a
vengeance to come and deal with
shigeraki
and the villain replies by saying that
this is one hell of a wake-up call
this moment is very reminiscent of
kamino where all might came flying in to
confront all for one
and the parallels are very clear as both
all might and endeavour were the number
one hero at the time
and the person they're fighting is an
all for one holder with multiple quirks
anyway my friends that was part two of
this war arc review
things are seriously about to heat up in
part 3 if you'll excuse the pun
shout out to my supporters on patreon
you guys are absolutely awesome
and special thanks to chronos gw who i
know was especially anticipating this
video
part 3 will be released in september
though like i said the exact date
depends on how many likes this video
gets
so be sure to hit that button if you
enjoyed it thanks for watching as always
and peace out
you